しきゅ
すいません寝癖が。
寝癖がひどいので
今日は帽子を被らせて頂きます
はい　という訳で久しぶりの文房具コーナーです
でまひとまずなんですけども
僕はこれで学生が一応終わったと
学生が終わると
恐らくなんですけど
シャーペンの使用率が減ります
うん
何かそんな気がする
今までね、何かこう
シャーペンを中心に紹介してきたんですけども
僕もそろそろ卒業かもしれません
いやまだ使うけどね
使うけども
ひょっとしたら多分ボールペンとかの方が
使う事が多いかもしれない
こういるんですよ
大学にもさ
何かこう　ちょっと大人ぶって
シャーペンを使うのを止めて
普通のノートの板書も全部ボールペンで
取ってる人とかもいたので
全然ボールペンを使ってみてもいいかなと思うんですけども
僕は～
ボールペンの知識がほぼないです
ほぼない
なんか、有名どころしか知らないです
ジェットストリームとかね、サラサとか
ビクーニャ、シグノ、フリクション
あ、結構知ってたわ
みなさんもなんかボールペン
聞いたことがあると思うんですよ
有名な名前をね
僕も、この先シャーペンよりボールペンを使うことが多くなるかもしれないので
ちょっといろんなボールペンを今日は比較していこうと思います
色んなボールペンの種類があると思うんですけれども、
僕が今回目を付けたのは
多機能ボールペンです
あの　多色ボールペンとも言いますね
いろんな色が入ってるボールペンで
中には　シャーペンが使えたり
タッチペンが使えたり
最近だと、色を変えれるやつ
ハイテックコレットとかスタイルフィット、スリッチーズ
こういう、なんかねぇ
もう、カスタマイズできるボールペンもあるんですけども
カスタマイズペンを抜いたボールペンの中の
多色ペン・多機能ボールペンについて
ちょっと比較していこうと思います
この時点で何言ってるか分かんない人
ごめんなさい！
文房具好きなんすよ
えへへ（ふっ）
ではいきましょう！
ちょっと六本ほど準備してみました
まずはこちら
エマルジョンボールペンです
太さが0.5、4色+シャープペン0.5
こんな感じですねー
Surariかな？
ん？俺の顔じゃないざ
デザインはかっこいいな
あ　消しゴムか
消しゴムがついてます
ペン先がちょっとおしゃれですね
Surariの多色ボールペンです
僕ねぇ　多機能ボールペン
なんかいつも思うんですけども
これ取るとさ
ペンがたくさんついてるわけじゃん
で　これを押すと
こう出るわけじゃん　ペンがね
で　出るんですけども
明らかに垂直に落ちてきてるわけじゃ
ないじゃないですか
5色のこの円の中から
少し斜め向いてから
まっすぐ落ちてくるんで
垂直ではないから
多分ペンのね　このね
ペン先がまっすぐ地面に垂直には
なってないと思うんですよ
何が言いたいかと言いますと
多色ペンのペン先は
少し傾いてる
間違いなく
ほら
ビミョーに傾いてるんですよ
微妙にね
微妙に曲がってるんで
多分書きにくかったり
ちょっと
引っかかったりすることが
あるかもしれません
そこはご了承ください
これだぁ！
次もZEBRAさんですね～
ZEBRA クリップ-オン マルチ
多機能ボールペン
シャープペン0.5+4色
はい　こんな感じです
クリップ-オン マルチ
金属光沢が出ててかっこいいです
かっこいいね
見た目はかなり好みのタイプですね
重みがあって
重心が低めです
ノックがすごいスムーズで
書きやすいです
なんかよくね　シャーペンとかボールペンでも
ペンでも全部そうなんですけども
このクリップが付いてるじゃないですか
挟むやつ
ここね
このクリップはただ挟むための
もののためだけじゃなくて
例えばこうテスト中ペンが落ちると
落ちるとコロコロ転がって落ちることがある
鉛筆とかね
そういう時このクリップがあると
ピタッと止まるんです
クリップは、物を止めるためのものだけじゃなくて
落ちる時のストッパーにもなるので、
クリップはなるべく大きい方がいいかもしれません
俺はいったい何を喋ってるんだ
これはー　有名でしょう
uniさんからのジェットストリームです
ああ　ちょっと先に
ジェットストリームの説明をしておくと
あのー
雑誌で見たんですけど
社会的現象が起きるほど
人気のボールペンです
すごい書きやすい
なめらかに書けます
はい来た！
ジェットストリームでございます！
こちらはシャーペン機能がないんですけども
4色、色があります
うん　スムーズスムーズ
出しやすい
このグリップがうまいこと
できてるんですよね～
一色しか使えないジェットストリームは
これと同じグリップの模様です
凝ってるねぇ
うぬ　かっこいいでしょう
ああ　来ました
ぺんてるさんからのビクーニャです
これも有名ですね
シャーペン機能なしの
4色のボールペンになっております
あんまり僕使ったことないんですよ
ビクーニャは
書きやすいってよく言われてるんで
多分書きやすいはずだと思います
極細だね
細かく字を書きたい人には
おすすめかもしれません
次
うーん　これはねぇ
次はこちら
僕が大好きDr.GRIPの
多機能ボールペンでございます
シャープペンシル0.5+油性ボールペン4色
0.7の細字です
なめらか低粘度アクロインキを
搭載しているみたいですー
よくわかりません
デザイン的にはもう◎じゃないですかね
PILOTのDr.GRIPでございます
洗練されたボディ
見た目的には1番じゃないでしょうか
グリップもしっかりしてるし
もう一つあるんですけども　こちら
たまたま見つけました
アクロボールホワイトライン
修正テープが付いてるんですね
0.7細字3色のボールペンなんですけども
ついに機能の中に修正テープまでついたか・・・
アクロボール機能が搭載されています
低粘度アクロインキ搭載
開けていきましょう
ほっ　おぉー　ノックがないよ
ああ　回すタイプね
回すと芯が回転するタイプです
これマジで修正テープなの？
こんな感じですねー
見た目はちょっとぱっとしないんですども
タイヤパターングリップ
しっかり握りやすいらしいです
回して芯が出るんですけども、
大事なのは書きやすさといったところではないでしょうか
かっけぇ
多機能ボールペンか・・・
ちょっと見た目の比較をしていきましょう
右からジェットストリーム
アクロボールの修正テープ付き
ZEBRAのクリップオンマルチ
Dr.GRIP
ビクーニャ
スラリ　となっております
厳ついね　やっぱり太いから
ではちょっと実際に書いてみましょう
まずは　ジェットストリーム！
クワオゥゥゥー
芯の太さは0.7
やあ　安定だわ
安定だわ！
ジェットストリームがやっぱり
一番書きやすいと思っちゃうんすよね
なめらかなんだよ　書き方が
サラッと書けるんすよ
いや　安定の書き心地ですね
とても書きやすい
次　アクロボールですね
アクロボールです
ちょっと修正テープの力を試してみたいんだよね
あ　やべ　事故った
やべ　事故った事故ったー
事故っちゃった
修正テープあるあるだ
なんか　絡まっちゃうんすよね
おー　なめらか
なめらかなめらか
書きやすいな
ジェットストリームとあまり大差無いです
このアクロボールってやつかなり書きやすいっすね
とてもなめらかに書けて良かったです
次　ZEBRAのクリップオンマルチ
こちらです
ジェットストリームと同じ太さなんですけども
ちょっと細いですね　気持ち
書きやすい
待ってなんか全部同じに感じてきちゃった
シャーペンも全然書きやすいです
Dr.GRIP
ちょっと推しメンなんで
ここ頑張ってもらいたいとこですな
こっちも0.7でございます
うおー　書きやすい
うぉ　お　おー
書きやすいぞ
なんかすっごいなめらかなんですけど
なめらかなめらかなめらか
でシャーペンも付いてるっしょ？
あー　やっぱシャーペンは
シャーペンはちょっとぶれますね
ちょっとカチカチしちゃいます
ちょっとシャーペンはぶれます
ビクーニャです
こっちは太さ0.5ですね
ちょっと細めに
ちょっと細めになります
うーん　細いね
ただ細字の人はすごいこれ気に入ると思います
細い字が好きな人は多分ビクーニャ一択ですね
はい　最後はこちらです
スラリですね
こちらも0.5
どのような書き心地なのでしょうか？
見ていきまっしょう
おぉ　おー
うわっ　たま～に色が
わー　これ色が抜けるな
色が抜けるぞ！
うわっ　これちょっと
うわー
わあぁぁぁぁ
わ　これ困るな
これ困る
色抜けるの困る
はい　というわけで
こんな感じになりましたー
どうでしょうか
微妙にインクの色も違うので
赤、青、緑にしても
微妙に色の違いがあると思います
へっ
へへへ
はい　というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
多機能・多色ボールペン
多色ボールペン
すごい種類多いんですよ今
文房具屋さんとか言っても
たくさん並んでると思うんで
なにかこう　ボールペンを選ぶ
参考になればいいなと思っております
僕のイチオシは
ま　ジェットストリームと
ドクターブリっ・・・
ハッ
Dr.GRIP
この二択だと思っております　今はね
まぁ使い込まないとわかんないところもあるので
一概には言えないと思うんですけども
ひとまずこの二択のどっちかを選んでおけば
間違いないと思っております
ジェットストリームはぜひ1回書いてもらいたい
なめらか感がものすごいです
皆さん・・・
文房具は・・・
いいですよ
ではまた次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな！